hey this is presh to Walker there's a
math problem that's gone viral on
Instagram with over 6 million views
I'll read the question out for you
there's a negative sign then 9 squared
plus 81.
what's the correct answer
tens of thousands of people are arguing
whether the correct answer is 162 or the
correct answer is zero
what do you think
in this video I'm going to explain the
correct answer according to the modern
interpretation of the order of
operations under that interpretation the
correct answer is zero I'm going to
explain why
we can remember the order of operations
by the acronyms PEMDAS or badmas this
refers to parentheses brackets exponents
orders multiplication and division and
addition and subtraction if you have two
operators of the same precedence
evaluate from left to right
in this expression we first evaluate the
exponent so we have 9 squared which is
equal to 9 times 9 which equals 81.
we then have the opposite of 81 plus 81
so we have an addition and that's equal
to zero and that's the correct answer
just for further illustration you could
type this expression into Google and it
will show you that the opposite of 9
squared plus 81 is equal to zero and
Google will even parse out so you see a
parenthesis around 9 squared so it's
evaluated first and then you take the
opposite of 9 squared so the opposite of
9 squared plus 81 is equal to 0.
but if you don't trust Google you could
even type this into Wolfram Alpha which
will show you the opposite of 9 squared
plus 81 is equal to zero
zero is the correct answer zip zilch
NADA shunya Squad douche
now if you didn't get this there is
widespread misunderstanding about this
concept
several years ago a study of prospective
Elementary teachers showed that they
incorrectly applied the order of
operations to compute the opposite of 3
squared
so it's not just students who get this
wrong but even sometimes teachers don't
evaluate this correctly
to further illustrate the point here's a
clip from a textbook that shows that the
opposite of 3 squared is evaluated as
the opposite of 3 times 3 which equals
negative nine this is definitely the way
that it's understood in mathematics
so why does this matter let's say you
have a function f of x is equal to the
opposite of x squared if you were to
graph this it would be a parabola
pointing downward
now F of nine would be equal to the
opposite of 9 squared which is equal to
negative 81 it is not equal to positive
81.
so you have the point nine comma
negative 81. the concept even applies in
higher mathematics here's an equation
for the standard normal curve
so you would take the opposite of Z
squared here and the standard normal
curve will look something like this so
the opposite of 9 squared plus 81 is
equal to zero and I hope that we can end
this widespread misunderstanding
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]